good that felt good
but don't worry new york's reopening and
you know como's been there the whole
time what is with this template they use
i don't know it's it's terrible but
listen to this
try not to get mad congratulations to
new yorkers because they
are the ones who did it we're no longer
just surviving
we're not in our homes afraid to go out
we're not in our homes disinfecting
everything that we can see
strange because we were never doing that
we didn't do that and we're totally
we're doing better than you
life is not about survival
life is about thriving how
[ __ ] dare you how [ __ ] dare you
sir
i know you the one that locked them up
you're the one that got the restaurants
all shut down and now
we're gonna open up all of the
businesses
and you're gonna see thriving in this
city you're gonna see amazon
thriving you're going to see mcdonald's
thriving shake shack thriving what am i
what about my dad's italian restaurant
your father
can't open up except the 10 capacity oh
oh no your father should have probably
gotten connected to the mob
like mine did then you would be more
successful
life is about seeing people life is
about loving
life is about celebrating life is about
enjoying
life is about grabbing interns asses and
getting away with it
life's about killing 15 000 old people
life
is about rubbing your [ __ ] through your
thousand dollar pants
while an intern eats a sausage in front
of you
that is what america was built on
interacting life is about having so much
spite
for your much more good-looking brother
who the family who's the family's
favorite
because you're so spiteful you'll become
the most successful one
all you listening people we get back to
living in life
the state mandates that
you know that's one of the probably the
cuomo fights do it thanksgiving is like
yeah well i am a governor so i mean by
those standards i'm more successful than
you
and you know chris cuomo is the one
that's like yeah you want to comply you
want to compare body fat percentages
you want to compare bank accounts where
you going bro
where you going bro i want to show you
my bank account it's you know
because you know chris probably has more
money than him too so so all andrew has
is i'm governor
i i really i don't want these guys to go
away because i think we have a good
couple more years on this show of
breaking down their horrible dynamic oh
yeah
you know it's funny zach has a good
point and this is uh
death santas forced their hand because
california just announced a reopening
too today like right before the show
because they're going to be out of
business
they're going to get they replaced
forced their hands they did they
they saw that florida has been open and
nothing is happening here
and and as much as they try to smear
desantis he
just continues to come off as cool yeah
which is bugging them
of course and there's none of this like
you know descent to scrap my titty
desantis told me to eat the whole
sausage there's none of this weird
you know what i mean it's every clip of
desantis is going today we've announced
that we're making youtube illegal you're
like man my homie
hell yeah and also we're making the lazy
river at busch gardens free
uh for all for all residents why let's
do it okay
cool and also i'm bringing back free or
be
free beer samples at busch gardens
that's been gone for a while we're
bringing them back you know why because
[ __ ] them that's why
and it's gonna be yingling beer bottled
right here in wonderful tampa lake let's
do it
it's just like damn this guy can't lose
right
and correct and brought us through this
pandemic
are relaxed as of today effective
immediately
i've been going to the gym for a month
yeah who locked it down
i can't believe fishing and agriculture
so they weren't people weren't even
allowed to go outside which is insane to
me this is what you should
this is how you should read this because
they're making it seem like
it's it's again like when a firefighter
starts a fire and then puts it out
that's what they're doing let's read
let's read this but look let's look at
us in a different way
not like effective immediately
restrictions that are lifted
let's read it this way things that for a
year have been restricted in new york
ready
sports and recreation not in florida
construction
definitely not in florida there have
been cranes even honestly
there's cranes in towns you don't expect
to see cranes where you're like oh boy
they're building towards the sky now
manufacturing was shut down
trade was restricted child care camps
food services offices real estate
buildings agriculture
fishing forestry amusement and family
entertainment
personal care services gyms retail malls
and movie theaters were all closed
you know what i don't you know what i
don't see on the list
schools are they still closing i don't
know so new york is still [ __ ] up
i don't know i mean the the lucky thing
that they have in this thing is that
they don't now have because schools are
on summer break now so they don't really
have to address it until after summer
break i do think we need to start school
in america next year everybody in person
and any teachers that refuse need to be
fired and replaced with teachers that
i agree we'll do it we're robots enough
of your [ __ ] listen hey teachers
you've already had
the easiest gig in the world you had the
easiest gig in the world
before covid and people are getting real
sick of your [ __ ]
all the state mandated restrictions are
lifted
on commercial and i want to point out i
know the audio is terrible but this is
from reuters it's not like i'm pulling
it like
from somebody's tv in another room
social settings
sports and recreation construction
manufacturing retail
we know we know we know we were all
across the board but yeah fishing and
agriculture and forestry so like you
couldn't even go fishing
that's correct which is nuts like even
in some states that had some lockdowns
you were still able to go like by
yourself
fishing which is something you do by
yours yeah you do alone you do that
i've been fishing every week yeah well
you're but you're doing you're doing it
as a as a rebel
you're in toronto they catch you you go
to jail yeah and plus
you put one of those it's actually
allowed you put one of those eskimo hats
on and just claim to be indigenous yeah
and they'll leave you canadians are like
sorry
sorry yeah so you're fine
dates are gone social gathering
restrictions the capacity restrictions
the health screening yeah but here's the
thing um
the thousands among thousands of people
the tens of thousands of people
that uh actually hundreds of thousands
of people that left your state
they're not going to come rushing back
now they're gone
even if they wanted to come back they're
like i already signed a lease and i'm
here we
moved we filled a moving truck i'm not
turning it they're not going back
it's done they're not going back
they're gonna go to a baseball game here
in tampa and then go y'all have a beer
wait it's how much wait you people live
this cheap here and you're gonna go yeah
it's this is it they're gonna go i'm not
going back to new york anyway there's
already more yankees fans and race fan
in tampa anyway so you're [ __ ] you're
fine
infecting protocols that's why those
games are always sold out yes
exactly why oh the yanks are in town all
right now i'll go to a game bring up my
hand sanitizer just yet by the way
i love that new york clean hand
sanitizer
okay can i can i suggest a video please
yes what's what yes what's new york
clean hands
do not remember that we covered it on
the show so they made a remember when he
said he was gonna have people in prisons
oh that's right yes that's right that's
right all right
so i gotta give a shout out to davey
croco and uh uh
[Music]
andy's random edits uh i'm trying to
find the video right now
this was one of the funniest videos ever
we've we've played this so many times on
night wave but um
here i'll send it to you now it's
perfect the new york clean hand
sanitizer
here we go boom all right let me have to
play it
shout out to andy's random edits and
davey croco he made this
like a year ago when he never heard of
those guys but okay yeah they're a
[ __ ]
pair of jerks really yeah i can guess
let's see here it's one of the funniest
videos ever this one
always makes me laugh all right let's
uh
all right oh wow kevin had already beat
me to it
open the curtain please we are
introducing
new york state clean hand sanitizer
made conveniently by
the state of new york this is a superior
process
products now on the market new york
state
clean hand sanitizer
purell competitor new york state
clean yeah [ __ ] you're talking about
purell that's an
inferior product what we have here we're
talking
75 alcohol hey this stuff's not on the
streets guys
if you continue the price gouging
we will introduce our product which is
superior to your product
hey let me tell you purell you think
you've got a [ __ ] product
you ain't seen nothing this is new york
state sanitizer
the
you guys want to raise the price we'll
take you right off the market
stay clean sanitizer made by the best
prisoners in the world
you still have to touch your hands you
put too much on your hands you're just
burning them off let me tell you
if we let this in ireland these people
will be killing themselves
nice
floral bouquet it cost us six dollars
so you want me to [ __ ] throw you down
that set of stairs even if you are
young and strong and everybody's
superman superwoman this was
you can give it to your grandparents you
can give it to your parent
everybody shilling this entire press
conference sister
friend in a vulnerable population
my mother and your mother hey andy
your mom doesn't love you hey yeah
[ __ ] i called her right before the
show
flora bouquet making it in the state of
new york
that's right order now for just three
easy payments
of 69.99 i've never loved you
mom never loved you i love them by the
way that's my favorite part of that
video is davey just taking low-key shots
with chris the whole time
i've
made by the best prisoners in the world